ALL UNFOLD FROM THERE.
JIM AND ERICA?
>> WE WILL BE WATCHING.
JESSICA DEAN, APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
>>> JOINING ME NOW TO DISCUSS A
JOE WALSH, A FORMER REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM ILLINOIS.
JOE, GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON THIS
MORNING.
>> GOOD TO BE WITH YOU, JIM.
>> SO I'M GOING TO SET ASIDE THE
VOTE COUNTING HERE BECAUSE WE
DID THAT LAST WEEK, WE DON'T
KNOW HOW THIS IS GOING TO GO ON
THIS PACKAGE, BUT IF AND WHEN A
RULES PACKAGE LIKE THIS GETS
THROUGH, DOES THAT MAKE FOR A
FUNCTIONING GOP-CONTROLLED
HOUSE?
>> OH, GOD, NO.
YOU KNOW, JIM, ONE OF THE
WEIRDEST THINGS ABOUT LAST WEEK,
THIS FIGHT TO FIND A SPEAKER,
WAS THE IRONY THAT IT REALLY
DOESN'T MATTER WHICH REPUBLICAN
ENDED UP BEING SPEAKER.
THIS IS A PRETTY FULLY
RADICALIZED MAGA TRUMP CAUCUS IN
THE HOUSE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE TRUMPISTS, ARE
ELECTION DENIERS.
WHAT WAS ALWAYS SO DECEPTIVE,
JIM, IS WE TALKED ABOUT THE 20,
THIS MINORITY OF 20 THAT OPPOSED
McCARTHY, BUT MARJORY TAYLOR JIM
AND JIM JORDAN SUPPORTED
McCARTHY BUT THEY ARE ALL GOING
TO BE TOGETHER ON ALL OF THESE
OTHER SUBSTANTIVE FIGHT THESE
NEXT TWO YEARS.
WE ARE IN FOR TWO YEARS OF UTTER
CHAOS.
>> WE KNOW WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
FOCUS ON.
STEVE SCALISE, NUMBER TWO IN THE
GOP LEADERSHIP IN THE HOUSE HE
TWEETED OUT A LIST OF GOP
PRIORITIES AND HE SAYS JUST
BEGINNING THIS WEEK, DEFUND
87,000 NEW IRS AGENTS, ESTABLISH
COMMITTEE ON THE WEAPONIZATION
AS THEY DESCRIBE IT OF FEDERAL
AGENCIES AND SALES TO CHINA,
HOLD WOKE PROSECUTORS
ACCOUNTABLE, DID HE NOT DEFINE
WOKE PROSECUTORS.
I WONDER FROM A POLITICAL
PERSPECTIVE, YOU'VE WON RACES
FOR THE HOUSE, IS THIS A WINNING
AGENDA FOR REPUBLICANS?
>> NOT AT ALL.
NOT WITH THE GENERAL ELECTORATE,
JIM, BUT IT'S A INN WINNING
AGENDA WITH THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
BASE, PERIOD.
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
LOOK, INVESTIGATING THE
SO-CALLED DEEP STATE, HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP, GOING AFTER DR.
FAUCI, THESE ARE ISSUES THAT THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BASE WANTS AND,
JIM, YOU KNOW LIKE I KNOW, THAT
THE HOUSE, THE BODY IN WHICH I
SERVED, MOST CLOSELY REFLECTS
THE BASE OF THE PARTY.
THIS WILL BE A TURN OFF, THIS
KIND OF LIKE MEGA REVENGE
INVESTIGATORY THING THAT THESE
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO DO THE
NEXT TWO YEARS I THINK WILL BE A
TURNOFF TO MOST AMERICANS BUT
IT'S GOING TO ENERGIZE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY BASE.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS AND WE'RE
GOING TO THROW UP MORE OF THESE
IMAGES HERE, THOSE IMAGES OF
SUPPORTERS OF THE LOSING
CANDIDATE IN THE BRAZILIAN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION JAIR
BOLSONARO STORMING THE HOUSES OF
GOVERNMENT THERE INCLUDING WHERE
THEIR ASSEMBLY MEETS.
YOU KNOW, WE USED TO TALK
ABOUT -- AND MANY FOLKS STILL
IMAGINE THIS, AND PERHAPS IT'S
TRUE TO SOME EXTENT -- THE U.S.
EXPORTS DEMOCRACY, BUT AS YOU
WATCH THIS AND HOW IT WAS CEDED
BY THE LOSING CANDIDATE IN THAT
ELECTION WHO HAD A LOT OF
RAPPORT MIGHT SAY WITH DONALD
TRUMP, IS ELECTION DENIALISM A
NEW U.S. EXPORT?
>> JIM, YOU KNOW THIS SO WELL
BECAUSE YOU TRAVEL THE WORLD SO
MUCH.
WE'RE THE WORLD'S OLDEST
DEMOCRACY.
THE WORLD -- THE REST OF THE
WORLD WATCHES US.
CLEARLY THE REST OF THE WORLD
WATCHED US ON JANUARY 6th.
I NEVER WOULD HAVE THOUGHT, JIM
SCIUTTO, THAT TWO YEARS REMOVED
FROM A VIOLENT ATTEMPT TO
OVERTHROW AN AMERICAN ELECTION
THAT YOU AND I WOULD BE SITTING
HERE AND DONALD TRUMP WOULD
STILL BE THE LEADER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY AND HE WOULD BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
THE WORLD WATCHED WHAT WE DID ON
JANUARY 6th AND TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY REALLY DIDN'T
PAY A PRICE.
MY FEAR IS THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT FLEDGELING
DEMOCRACIES AROUND THE WORLD ARE
LEARNING FROM US.
>> YEAH, AND MANY OF THE FOLKS
WHO DENIED THE RESULTS OF